tenemos algunas palabras aquí que nos
hablan de las diferentes reacciones nos
dicen si absorben o liberan diferentes
tipos de energía vemos la primera
palabra exotérmica la raíz de la palabra
externos que se refiere a calentar y
esta palabra significa una reacción que
libera calor
libera
calor
y una manera de pensar en ello si estás
pensando en presiones constantes un
cambio en la antártida puede ser visto
como la cantidad de calor que se absorbe
o se libera así que un cambio negativo
en la antártida significa que se está
liberando calor una forma de pensar en
ello si vemos a la entropía como el
contenido de calor hay menor contenido
de calor después de la reacción que
antes lo que significa que se está
liberando calor lo que significa que el
cambio en la antártida va a ser menor
que cero por lo tanto todo esto
significa lo mismo bueno esto es lo
mismo que liberar calor si la presión es
constante presión
kant tanto
ahora basándonos en esa lógica que crees
que significa esta palabra endotérmicos
bueno endo térmico tiene la misma raíz
termos y ahora su prefijo es en dos por
lo que este es un proceso que absorbe
calor absorbe calor o si estás pensando
en tener una presión constante se puede
decir que la entropía después de la
reacción va a ser más alta que la
entropía antes de la reacción así que su
delta h va a ser mayor que 0 muy bien
ahora echemos un vistazo a estos dos
conceptos exergo niko y ender gonik o
vemos exergo niko la raíz aquí es argón
y puede que no estés tan familiarizado
con esta raíz como podrías estarlo con
ternos pero es posible que hayas oído la
palabra ergonómico puede que hayas
escuchado a alguien decir
escritorio es ergonómico esto significa
que es un escritorio que es bueno para
trabajar en el decir esta es una silla
ergonómica y ergo viene del griego y
significa trabajo por lo tanto una
reacción exergo nica es aquella que
libera energía en forma de trabajo o al
menos eso es lo que implica la palabra
libera energía en forma de trabajo
libera
y energía
forma
d
atrás bajo
y en dragón y ccoo utilizando la misma
lógica va a absorber la energía en forma
de trabajo o utilizar la energía en
forma de trabajo
o utilizar la energía
en forma
d
atrás
bajo
ahora una de las propiedades que podemos
utilizar para pensar acerca de la
energía que puede ser utilizada para
generar trabajo es la energía libre de
hips y la fórmula para la energía libre
de jeeps si estamos pensando en que el
sistema está a presión y temperatura
constantes a presión
temperatura
constante
la fórmula para la energía libre de
jeeps o incluso se puede ver como una
definición de la energía libre de jeeps
el cambio en la energía libre de jeeps
es igual
el cambio en la entropía
- la temperatura multiplicado por el
cambio en la entropía y si esto te
parece completamente extraño te invito a
ver el vídeo sobre energía libre de
jeeps y la razón por la que esto está
relacionado con la energía en forma de
trabajo es que esto me dice si estoy
absorbiendo o liberando calor y estoy
restando la entropía que es la energía
que se añade al desorden del universo y
lo que queda es la energía que puedo
utilizar para generar trabajo esa es una
manera de pensar en ello por lo que se
puede ver que aquí se relacionan la
energía en forma de trabajo con el
cambio en la entalpía por lo tanto
exergo niko es algo que libera energía
en forma de trabajo se podría decir que
tiene menos energía en forma de trabajo
después de la reacción que antes de la
reacción su ventaja va a ser menor que
cero
y estas reacciones que liberan energía
en forma de trabajo son consideradas
como espontáneas estas de aquí las que
absorben la energía en forma de trabajo
van a tener más energía en forma de
trabajo en el sistema después de la
reacción que antes por lo que su delta
que va a ser mayor que cero y decimos
que éstas no son espontáneas
ahora que tenemos las definiciones y
tenemos una manera de relacionar estas
variables echemos un vistazo a estos
diferentes escenarios de las reacciones
que son exotérmicas y exergo nicas o
exotérmicas gender cónicas y ver por qué
tienen sentido de manera intuitiva esta
primera reacción es exotérmica su delta
h es menor que cero eso significa que
tiene menos entalpía después de la
reacción que antes lo que significa que
libera calor puedes ver aquí que se está
liberando calor y de donde vino esa
energía pues cuando se une en esta nueva
configuración los electrones son capaces
de ir a estados de energía menores y
liberar esa energía y el calor si
pensamos a una escala microscópica es
algo que aumenta la temperatura al menos
localmente lo que implica la
transferencia de energía cinética a
estas moléculas recuerda que cuando
hablamos de calor o temperatura pensamos
en estas variables a nivel
pero a nivel microscópico estamos
hablando de la energía cinética y la
energía potencial entre otras así que lo
que ocurre es que estos electrones
cuando adoptan una nueva configuración
van a liberar energía que se puede
transferir a las moléculas individuales
así que sea liberado energía y también
hay un aumento en la entropía tenemos
más entropía después de la reacción que
antes de la reacción
tenemos más objetos aquí hay más estados
en los que podrían estar y se están
moviendo más rápido así que si aplicamos
esta fórmula esto va a ser menor que
cero delta ese va a ser mayor que cero
la temperatura que va a ser la
temperatura absoluta en que albín
siempre va a ser positiva por lo que
este término va a ser positivo y un
negativo menos un positivo nos va a dar
un negativo así que nuestro delta g va a
ser menor que cero y vemos que esta es
espontánea
esta reacción va a avanzar de izquierda
a derecha y tiene sentido libera energía
a los electrones les gusta se crea un
estado más desordenado otra forma de
pensar en ello es tratar que la reacción
se lleve a cabo en el otro sentido
tendríamos que conseguir un poco de
energía para que los electrones puedan
llegar a un estado de energía más alto
cuando forman estos nuevos enlaces
tendríamos que conseguir que estos
cuatro componentes se junten de una
manera determinada eso parece mucho
menos probable que suceda que ir de
izquierda a derecha ahora vamos a pensar
en una reacción que absorbe calor y esto
parece ir en contra de nuestra intuición
absorbe el calor iba a ser espontánea va
a ser hexagon y acá va a llevarse a cabo
espontáneamente así que berta h es mayor
que 0 por lo que para poder suceder
absorbe calor así que tengo estas dos
moléculas con estos diferentes
constituyentes
y están a punto de colisionar y decimos
que la temperatura es alta si la
temperatura fuera baja esto podría no
ser espontáneo pero si la temperatura es
lo suficientemente alta si será
espontánea a una temperatura alta visto
a un nivel microscópico observamos que
estas moléculas tienen una muy alta
energía cinética y van a chocar entre sí
muy rápido van a chocar entre sí tan
rápido que van a formar todas estas
otras partículas así que la entropía
neta aumenta y los electrones están en
un estado de energía más alto para poder
formar estas estructuras por lo que
tuvieron que absorber la energía térmica
y podríamos llamarlo calor pero cuando
hablamos de calor a un nivel
microscópico estamos hablando de la
energía cinética de estas moléculas pero
de dónde vino esa energía bueno vino de
la energía cinética de las moléculas
tenían una cierta energía cinética antes
algo de esa energía se pierde cuando las
moléculas adoptan configuraciones
diferentes y si todavía no entiendes muy
bien esto piensa en tratar de llevar a
cabo la reacción en sentido opuesto
trata de hacer que estos cuatro
componentes estén juntos en el momento
adecuado aun estando juntos de la forma
correcta sus electrones pueden llegar a
una configuración tal que liberen
energía pero esto está sucediendo a muy
alta temperatura este es un sistema muy
muy caótico no va a ir de derecha a
izquierda va a ir de izquierda a derecha
cuando la reacción es realmente caótica
y las cosas están chocando a gran
velocidad es más probable que vaya en la
dirección de mayor entropía así que esta
reacción es espontánea a pesar de que
absorbe calor y si no se está drenando
el calor a nivel local la temperatura
alrededor de estas moléculas va a bajar
pero estamos a una temperatura constante
en esta reacción por lo que se puede
suponer que a un nivel macro esa
temperatura se disipa
sobre fuera del sistema de alguna manera
ahora echemos un vistazo a esta
configuración es exotérmica de modo que
delta h es menor que cero menos entalpía
después de la reacción que antes por lo
que está librando calor pero no es
espontánea y no es espontánea porque
está reduciendo la entropía del universo
y la entropía es importante porque la
temperatura en esta reacción es alta una
forma de ver esta ecuación es que la
entropía no tiene importancia cuando la
temperatura es baja la temperatura está
reduciendo considerablemente la entropía
pero cuando la temperatura es alta la
entropía comienza a tomar importancia
esta variable comienza a ser de suma
importancia así que aquí debido a que la
entropía es negativa esta reacción no va
a suceder así que si estas moléculas se
estuvieron acercando muy lentamente sus
electrones se podrían configurar en la
manera correcta para que puedan llegar a
un estado de energía más baja
y liberar energía pero en realidad están
pasando una al lado de la otra tan
rápido que no van a tener la oportunidad
de hacer eso y si pensamos en la
reacción en el otro sentido es mucho más
probable que suceda si tenemos un montón
de moléculas de atómicas van a chocar
entre sí tan rápido que se van a
deshacer y sus componentes quedarán
fuera de estas moléculas de atómicas o
al menos por la forma en que la dibujé
parece que es una molécula de atómica y
podrían absorber parte de esa energía
cinética al hacerlo para poder ir de
derecha a izquierda y eso es más
probable que ocurra así que si la
reacción va de izquierda a derecha no es
espontánea porque la entropía realmente
tiene importancia cuando estamos a esta
alta temperatura y finalmente este tipo
de reacción es muy intuitiva tenemos una
reacción que necesita calor que necesita
energía térmica tiene una disminución en
la entropía y definitivamente no
hacer espontánea así que este es mayor
que 0 este es menor que cero pero lo
estamos restando así que todo este
término es mayor que cero por lo que
este verdad va a ser mayor que cero este
delta g va a ser mayor que es cero y
tiene sentido tenemos estas dos
moléculas que tenemos que juntar de la
manera correcta necesitan calor con el
fin de que esta reacción proceda para
poder excitar a los electrones y que
pasen a un estado de energía mayor para
poder unirse en este enlace que es menos
estable porque harían eso es mucho más
probable que la reacción ocurra de esta
manera si tenemos un montón de estas
moléculas todos están golpeando entre sí
llegan a una configuración más estable y
hay menos entropía cuando se separan que
cuando se quedan juntas así que su delta
g es mayor que cero estas reacciones en
armónica y endo térmica y por supuesto
en esta el delta g es mayor que cero
y a pesar de que aquí se libera energía
el sistema es tan caótico que no van a
poder hacer eso y es mucho más probable
que vaya en la dirección que aumente la
entropía por lo que esta reacción
tampoco es espontánea